we've now learned that he had also
previously been on the radar of the
security service mi5 they started
investigating him uh in the back half of
2020 and i understand that the
suspicions about him were related to
islamist terrorism and what was
described as a short lead investigation
which is something that's short of a
longer-term
covert investigation of a subject of
interest that it concluded that there
was no threat to national security at
that time
and in terms of how long that
investigation lasted i understand that
it was more than four weeks it might
have concluded therefore at the back end
of 2020 or
as uh as late as the early part of 2021
but to give you some kind of context of
the threat that mi5 is having to contend
with there are at any time about between
three and four thousand subjects of
interest that they're looking at and
when it came to akram they'd obviously
had some sort of intelligence that he
might pose a threat they'd investigated
that intelligence to see how credible it
was and at the end decided that at that
time he didn't pose a threat so
therefore he is part of the ranks of
some 40 000 previous subjects of
interest